[Music]
so i'm going to reduce the notes and
patterns down into chords i can simplify
the right hand into these chords
[Music]
you can simplify it even further
[Music]
and then the next eight measures
everything shifts over to d
with that in mind i understand the
pattern better because it's basically
arpeggiating between those four notes
going up
two or three octaves and then back down
two or three octaves
so this is what i came up with
[Music]
so really you can do anything i'm not
really thinking too much about
functional harmony nor am i keeping in
mind everything that i previously
analyzed i'm just examining things that
i like about how the chords move from
one to the next in the original form and
i'm trying to apply certain aspects of
those into my new chords for example i
want to keep the fact that these chords
are moving downwards
[Music]
and each one has a tension note or
non-chord tone resolving into the chord
and finally apply the pattern to the new
chords first chord
second chord
third chord
[Music]
last chord
[Music]
you